return of politics now we are less than
two weeks away from election day
and tonight president trump returns to
the battleground state of north carolina
after holding a rally last night in erie
pennsylvania now the latest
cbs news battleground tracker shows the
president
trailing democratic rival joe biden in
pennsylvania
trump narrowly won that state back in
2016. last night the president took aim
at 60 minutes though for an interview
earlier that day at the white house
he threatened to release the interview
before it airs
you have to watch what we do to 60
minutes you'll get such a kicker
you're going to get a kick out of it
leslie stalls not going to be happy
while the president travels to north
carolina tonight former vice president
joe biden he is off the campaign trail
right now
he is preparing for tomorrow night's
final presidential debate in nashville
meanwhile former president barack obama
is holding his first
in-person campaign event on biden's
behalf and that's happening tonight
over in philadelphia we'll follow all
that for you tonight